what's going on reject nation I'm Greg I
am forced to be here yes she is we're
gonna watch the trailer for Far Cry six
the official reveal one fee tree Oh hold
on everyone hold on a minute
everyone hold on wait we're waiting just
wait excuse me we're waiting Oh trying
to put my hair in a ponytail now similar
except really weird what are you doing
Oh Oh the fans of Giancarlo will know
they'll appreciate this aha
Lost Boy Oh sir mano she hasn't seen
Breaking Bad the deal was we'd watch The
Sopranos
if we just finished that and then I
would show her Breaking Bad afterwards a
man I love Giancarlo Esposito so cool
the boys Moff Gideon of course Gus from
Breaking Bad and better call Saul I
mainly want to watch this just to see
Giancarlo it's not even really the game
just chunk are you excited yeah exactly
it's frozen
fascist
inappropriate for children already yes
Wow perfect but useless
I have something give me a hand grenade
it has four basic parts the shell which
contains the explosive defuse the handle
and of course
it is only when you let it go
goodbye good luck the end of I know what
my parents are like this
they do not know how happy they are torn
apart my opinion see boys if it's a
strangled even if you have love in your
heart even if you want what's best for
them if you only want to save them from
themselves
they were made to be long already you
say dude me general
Wow holy crap it's like stay here
surreal
Oh
are you
our culture is like his granny is that
there's two basic parts
ha
and you
we
that's one way to look at
fascism I guess
Wow watch more from for my six that's
pretty that's pretty yeah correct I'm
someone who goes to multiple protests
this is really hitting home imagine for
you especially this is like one of those
amazing cinematic trailers where you
kind of forget you're watching a game
trailer for a second that you think this
could just be an awesome TV show or
something like that or a really cool
relevant dramatic intense political
movie the short little narrative
exploring the theme of being in this
Diego yeah than being in Diego shoes
obviously he's the main character and
it's interesting that you're setting up
this wonderful dichotomy this yeah this
compelling relationship his father El
Presidente is clearly the villain of
this story not for people who like
fascism that's true so in our eyes he's
a protagonist
[Laughter]
I was just rying to pander to those who
thought that with John Carlos was you
know always does so well with playing
the countless villains he plays he
always plays him in a way where he
evidently does not view himself like
he's the bad guy
even though you know he's the villain I
never do I think people in power
especially those people in general don't
ever view themselves as a bad guy they
truly think that they are doing what's
best for the country and this is the way
it needs to be it was probably the
perfect person to play this that type of
the real John Carla because them how he
is Giancarlo and real not someone like
you yeah I know I mean I'm just a
narcissist but I'm not gonna be like
this level though we'll see we'll see
how far I can take it I like this setup
of Diego just that dynamic of dad that
interest
this is your father to be the
protagonist but have to go against your
father eventually at some point in the
game and using the philosophy and the
metaphor of what
Giancarlo's character el Presidente is
using with the grenade to represent the
divided and the people I just thought
was a really well constructed narrative
I thought it was great at haunting you
know in a lot of ways and this has been
in development for quite a while so
which means they've probably taken
portions of what's going on politically
in our environment yeah
confuse in the game as well I mean is
this like is there a country right now
that I'm you know way better than I
would be on America kind of get this
Fidel Castro vibe a little bit from him
it's definitely taking cuz he's a
guerrilla soldier eventually so it's
definitely taking from Fidel Castro but
also playing off of there's a famous
guerrilla soldier I don't remember Jake
yeah I think that's really what they're
going for here so I think they're really
taking nice party with that story but
infusing modern-day oh yeah yeah that's
a nice day this looks pretty freakin
right and thing you say with all these
games that it sounds like a broken
record at this point those graphics are
nuts cuz a lot of times when you put
famous not all the time there are
certain games where they do it amazingly
but sometimes it looks kind of weird
when you got like an actual famous actor
who they're using a mocap for a
character and then there's kind of this
uncanny valley effect sometime and then
here when they do the close-up on his
face it looked flawless to the point
where I'm like wow he's like actually in
the game and it didn't have that weird
tight I don't know though of the word
I'm looking for here but sometimes
sometimes it's like there's a lack of
life in the face because I'm so used to
seeing the actor in Rio and like real
life format but seeing him here I'm like
all the expression is there in the
blinking even is all there it looks
great all right cries six man there's
gonna be a what I'm excited to do is go
through the comments later to see all
the Gus fring references and also
probably Dora and Diego you know how the
internet can be
all right guys Dora Diego yeah Oh Lord
trust me I know how the Internet is or
I've just started it like you know what
if you happen to go to the video just
look up the comments the video these
comments came before this video went
live that I'm safe all right
or I've started a revolution subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell toaster top six down
below last but not least let's do a
Jason Dolan so a pun deciding who to
shout out in this video we said who's
the whitest guy we can shout out at our
patreon page we found him
Jason you know honestly Jason yeah
jason has been an amazing friend who
held the camera shooting off of he gave
to us beyond that like I've been able to
reach out to him for very important
things he's so he actually went there
pretty big loss recently so I'm sorry
for what you've had to go through with
that I've talked to you about that and
messages already I don't know if you
fall in love social media but he's a
hardcore activist oh really yeah
hardcore activist we were to get along
with you so boom we love hanging out
with you ya know now that's just a
cherry on top because the more she
approves it to you the better off you
are with coming in this home that's
right John's on his way out so so we
need to replace them Jason one white guy
friend oh yeah we got that balance of
course he's got a woman on here too much
- whoa - whoa damn women who woke thanks
Jason
stay heck